une culture une civilisation alors
est-ce que ça bonjour à tous et merci de
nous retrouver sur public sénat sans
plus tarder nous allons prendre la
direction de la salle médicis où la
commission des affaires économiques du
sénat auditionne les ministres concernés
par la sphère de la viande de cheval
tout de suite donc cette audition bon
après midi à tous sous la marque sur
lesquels elles étaient vendues c'est pas
la peine de leur faire la publicité
pas plus qu'à l'entreprise de
transformation en tous les cas j'ai
souhaité organiser cette audition pour
éclairer la commission je me félicite in
fine et que vous soyez que vous soyez
venu à 3 en sachant que le ministre le
foll qui est à l'heure actuelle dans
l'hémicycle sur le débat sur la ruralité
l'avenir des campagnes nous rejoindre a
aussitôt que ce débat sera terminée bien
je pense que le plus simple est de
suivre le fil conducteur partir en fait
de la fraude à la consommation de parler
ensuite de la transformation et ensuite
de la production autrement dit
l'ensemble de la filière voilà le fil
rouge que je vous propose
en vous rappelant quand même qu'il
faudrait pas qu'il ya une confusion
entre une fraude sur la nature de la
viande et qui n'est pas qu'ils
n'engendrent pas une crise sanitaire
comme on a pu connaître faut pas
mélanger les choses
et même je le dis posément avoir de la
viande de cheval à la place de la viande
de boeuf et peut-être au niveau
nutritionnel une meilleure solution
c'est moins calorifique et ça apporte
plus de protéines au kg non mais je
positive par rapport aux choses et
arrêter cette espèce de phobie qui
pourrait s'installer autour de la viande
de boeuf et de cheval bien monsieur le
ministre à man vous avez seule la parole
pour nous faire peut-être un rappel
historique de ce qui s'est passé de ce
que vous avez fait et de ce qui est en
train de se faire
merci monsieur le président je vais vous
rappeler pour commencer quelques
éléments factuels sur cette enquête et
sur les conclusions qui ont été celles
du service national des enquêtes de la
dgccrf conclusions qui ont été
transmises au parquet et parquet qui je
crois a décidé de diligenter une enquête
puisque aujourd'hui même je crois qu'à
certaines auditions sont en cours à
l'entreprise spanghero de la réalité
c'est que la dgccrf a été alerté le 5
février par deux canaux différents
d'abord les autorités luxembourgeoises
le luxembourg où se situent les usines
tavola qui appartient au groupe français
comme il l est par
les communes elles elles mêmes les
entreprises comédienne elle même qui a
saisi les services de la dgccrf de
moselle donc par ce double canal nous
avons commencé des investigations et des
investigations qui nous ont amené à
révéler quoi que dans cette filière qui
remontent jusqu'à un abattoir en
roumanie fait intervenir des
intermédiaires et traders à chypre et
aux pays bas
en l'occurrence une société qui
s'appelle drap trading deux entreprises
françaises sont concernées par ce qui
pourrait relever d'une tromperie
économique de grande envergure telle que
nous l'avons commencé à la révéler
puisqu'elle met en jeu la
commercialisation de plus de quatre
millions et demi de plats cuisinés dans
13 pays
28 entreprises ce qui est aujourd'hui
assez considérable ces deux entreprises
sont un importateur de viande
l'entreprise spanghero qui outre qu'il
importe de la viande en france d'une
part en livres pour une partie a commis
gènes qui lui elle pardon prépare des
plats cuisinés de toutes sortes mais
d'autre part à une activité qui est une
activité de transformation de cette
viande puisque la société spanghero
elle-même réalise un certain nombre de
plats cuisinés et commercialise une
partie de la viande
aung au détail qu'elle a achetés sur le
marché européen qu'est-ce que l'anc est
que nous avons réalisée permet d'établir
pour faire assez vite puisque je crois
qu'on n'a pas beaucoup de temps en
intervention liminaire a été constaté
que les palettes de vianne en tout cas
les pain de viande qui entrait chez
spanghero étaient étiquetés avec un code
douanier qui est un code douanier que
connaissent tous les professionnels de
la viande ce code douanier tant
qu'aumônier utilisant toute l'union
européenne mettant le quad donniez de la
viande de cheval
estampillée en provenance de roumanie et
avec une mention qui disait que c'était
bf qui ne veut pas dire bof mais bonne
les forces qui veut dire
morceaux d'animaux en haut avant
d'animal désosser la l'étiquetage de ces
produits arrivés chez eux comme chez
spanghero a attiré l'attention des
enquêteurs du s2 et de la dgccrf
pourquoi parce que quand ils sortent de
chez spanghero pour allécher commises
elles mêmes pain de viande sont
étiquetés avant de boeuf désossée et non
plus
bf c'est à dire avant d'animal désossé
que laisse tant pis roumanie a disparu
pour indiquer provenance viande
provenant de l'union européenne et de
surcroît aux coptes ne trouve aussi sur
un charme de ces factures un code
douanier qui n'est pas le code denis de
la viande de cheval mais cette fois ci
le code douanier de la viande de boeuf
suffisamment de faits et un faisceau
d'indicés va dire graves et concordants
qui laisse entendre que un certain
nombre de dirigeants de spanghero aurait
pu connaître
vous connaissez le fait ou savait
parfaitement qu'il a acheté de la viande
de cheval pour la revendre au prix de la
viande de boeuf
qu'est ce qui a alerté également les
agents du service national des enquêtes
le prix d'achat de ces pain de viande
puisque ils sont achetés très en deçà ou
à un prix étonnamment sous la moyenne
des prix de la viande de boeuf sur le
marché européen est revendue par contre
au prix de la viande de boeuf
les professionnels du secteur nous
disant que la marge qu'ils réalisaient
par les professionnels à cette étape est
autour de 10 à 15 centimes en
l'occurrence pang héros réalisé une
marge d'au tour plus de plus de 20 euros
sur chaque kilo de viande vendue pendant
une période de six mois sur un volume de
750 tonnes sur ses 750 tonnes de viande
de cheval qui on était
donc commercialisé en lieu et place de
la viande de boeuf plus de 500 tonnes
vont à coup michel et 200 tonnes vont à
l'utilisation de spanghero pour ses
propres produits
ce qui laisse apparaître donc une
tromperie économique d'un montant qui
pourrait tourner autour de 550 mille
euros de bénéfices réalisés grâce à la
vente de viande de cheval a commis gel
en lieu et place de la viande de boeuf
voilà ce qui vous donne quelques
éléments de se dire très factuelle de ce
qui a été constaté plus une série
d'autres faits constatés à la fois par
la dgccrf confirmée par les services
vétérinaires quand ils ont à la demande
du ministre de l'agriculture une mise de
l'agroalimentaire étaient dépêchés sur
place
après la suspension de l'agrément
sanitaire
nous avons là un faisceau d'indicés
graves et concordants qui justifiait
qu'à nos yeux il fallait transmettre au
parquet et que nous soupçonnions une
tromperie économique que se passe-t-il
désormais pour ce qui me concerne sur
cette affaire-là où les agents de la
ccrf ils apportent leur concours
oh
services compétents et en l'occurrence à
la gendarmerie dès lors qu'ils sont
sollicités pour le faire mais nous avons
voulu et je veux insister là dessus en
lien permanent et étroit entre le
ministère l'agriculture
l'agroalimentaire et bercy élargir le
champ de notre enquête parce que ce que
nous voulons faire c'est la lumière sur
une filière qui doit restaurer sa
crédibilité pour qu'on ne se retrouve
pas à devoir gérer des plans sociaux
demain en aval de la filière chez qui
j'ai toutes celles et ceux qui
commercialisent des produits surgelés ou
des plats préparés les chiffres dont
nous disposons aujourd'hui c'est que sur
le week-end les plats préparés
la baisse de la vente de ces plats
préparés de l'ordre de 5 % 20 % en
grande-bretagne il ya donc là un effet
direct est lié à une crise de confiance
vis-à-vis de ses plats cuisinés
ce présent vous avez raison la viande de
cheval n'est pas impropre à la
consommation
mais quand vous achetez du boeuf voulais
avoir du boeuf dans votre assiette c'est
assez légitime et pas du cheval surtout
quand vous savez que certains se font
une belle petite marge sur le fait de
vous vendre du cheval à la place du
boeuf
c'est ce lac sur lequel nous sommes
aujourd'hui concentrée qui mobilise
évidemment l'enquète comment avons voulu
avons-nous voulu élargir lé enquête de
deux manières d'abord en faisant
l'inventaire de toute la comptabilité de
la société communale à qui nous avons
pointé ses propres négligences le fait
de recevoir des pain de viande étiqueté
provenance union européenne aurait dû
alerter aussi commis gel sur la
composition du produit qu'ils achetaient
se devait est estampillé du pays en
provenance de la viande ça n'était pas
le cas nous avons aussi indiqué que
pour n'importe quel boucher pour
n'importe quel contrôleur de la viande
de cheval et la viande de boeuf à
l'odeur au toucher au regard ça se
reconnaît quasi immédiatement la société
commune viennent nous apporter un centre
de réponse il ne m'appartient pas
maintenant de dire si elles sont
satisfaisants tout peuple ce que l'
enquête relève aujourd'hui d'autres
services mais nous avons voulu faire
aussi l'inventaire de la comptabilité
aval de komi gel pour identifier la
totalité des entreprises et des pays
vers lesquels étaient partis des plats
cuisinés avec du cheval à la place du
boeuf sur quoi se sont concentrées
ensuite nos enquêtes sur la réalité des
retraits réalisés par les entreprises
dans les grandes surfaces dans les lieux
de distribution de ses produits la
réalité de ces retraits depuis la
semaine dernière nous avons réalisé 538
intervention dans 70 départements pour
vérifier que les produits incriminés
n'était pas elle était bien retirés la
deuxième chose que nous avons fait et là
c'est dans le cadre d'un plan élaboré en
commun avec le ministre de l'agriculture
le ministre de l'agro alimentaire qui se
préoccupent évidemment de la crédibilité
de la filière c'est de contrôler à côté
de la filière roumanie spanghero commis
gel je reviens pas son intermédiaire
néerlandais il semble lui aussi
intéressant de creuser ce qu'il a fait
et ça relève évidemment une enquête des
autorités néerlandaises avant des
autorités françaises et donc nous avons
voulu contrôler des échantillons de
produits de plats surgelés qui n'ont
rien à voir avec cette filière là pour
voir si d'autres filières
d'approvisionnement de transformation et
de commercialisation de viande de boeuf
ou des chevals du coi dires des uns
étaient concernés ce travail-là amènera
à ce que nous produisions les résultats
de l' enquête dans les jours qui
viennent pour indiquer si li à d'autres
filières qui sont concernés mais il
était clair qu'il fallait circonscrire
le dossier en l'occurrence qui nous
était le problème qui nous étaient
posées essayé d'embrasser la totalité de
la situation le sort de l'ensemble de la
filière et des dizaines de milliers
d'emplois qui sont concernés la
confiance des consommateurs ils sont des
millions à avoir été bernés et pas
seulement en france et des pays
européens se retourne vers nous
évidemment le sort des salariés de
spanghero et nous l'avons dit et répété
j'en terminerai par là pour que le
ministre de l'agro alimentaire
reviennent sur les raisons qui ont
justifié que par précaution nous levions
où nous suspendions arnon l'agrément
sanitaire
je veux insister sur ce point à nos yeux
ni les salariés de son héros ni les
salariés de la filière aval ni les
consommateurs n'ont à payer les pots
cassés pour le comportement qui pourrait
être celui de quelques dirigeants d'une
entreprise dont nous disons aujourd'hui
que les dirigeants de cette entreprise
en tout cas ce qui relève de la tutelle
puisse qu'ils appartiennent à une
coopérative doivent
regarder un petit peu ce qui se passe
chez eux quand une de telles accusations
sont portées contre le management de
l'entreprise
je comprends que les salariés se
coalisent parce qu'ils ont peur de
perdre leur emploi
mais là encore nous nous faisons la
différence entre des travailleurs qui
travaillent bien font correctement leur
boulot nettoient leurs l'entreprise
assure que c'est la viande de qualité
qui sort qui n'est pas une cave viande
impropre à la consommation une
manifestement des dirigeants qui
auraient pu je mets des conditionnels
organisé un système de changement
d'étiquette
entre l'arrivée de la viande et la
sortie de cette viande
voilà je vous remercie monsieur le
ministre je pense que la réponse ultra
rapide que vous avez faite concernant le
retrait d'agrément a coupé court sans
doute à une panique qui aurait pu
s'instaurer en mélangeant la fraude
économique simplement et un problème
sanitaire concernant les produits à la
consommation
monsieur le ministre de l'agro
alimentaire vous avez la parole merci
monsieur le président mesdames messieurs
les sénateurs
d'abord je voudrais vous remercier de
votre invitation pour c'est un plaisir
partagé monsieur président voilà
stéphane le foll nous rejoindra dans
quelques instants
moi je voudrais dire deux ou trois deux
ou trois choses assez simples pour
engager le dialogue et répondre surtout
à vos questions mais deux ou trois
choses qui m'apparaissent fondamentales
sur la façon dont nous avons traité ce
dossier
notre ligne elle était simple en
définitive il nous fallait intervenir
avec rapidité avec fermeté et avec
discernement
c'est ce qui a motivé motivé et c'est ce
qui continue de motiver chacune de nos
interventions
chacune de nos expressions
il y a eu une enquête administrative qui
a été conduite à la fois par la
répression des fraudes et par les
services de l'alimentation cette enquête
benoît hamon vient de vous en livrer les
principales conclusions a conclu à une
suspicion de fraude et à suspicions de
négligences
par ailleurs première chose
cette enquête nous l'avons présenté en
toute transparence aux français la
semaine passée parce que nous devons ça
non seulement consommateur
mais plus fondamentalement aux citoyens
qui attendent leurs gouvernants que nous
traitions l'ensemble de ces dossiers
avec responsabilité et vérité première
chose donc une enquête administrative
ensuite nous avons voulu immédiatement
doublé ses conclusions d'une enquête
sanitaire qui est je vous le dis rendu
obligatoire par le code rural
ça n'est pas un supplément qui viennent
non cette obligatoire et donc nous avons
immédiatement la semaine passée c'était
vendredi de la semaine passée une fois
que les conclusions de l'enquêté
administrative était connue lancé cette
enquête sanitaire avec déplacement sur
site de la brigade nationale vétérinaire
pour faire quoi pour contrôler la
conformité sanitaire de l'établissement
en cause
stéphane le foll a suspendu l'agrément
je dis bien suspendu l'agrément de
l'entreprise qui veut fait qu'il faisait
l'objet de ces examens ne s'agit pas
d'un retrait une suspension et cette
enquête a conclu hier dans la journée
qu' il n'y avait pas de problème
sanitaire
c'est très important de rappeler de
rappeler cette vérité pas de problème
sanitaire
mais nous avons voulu isoler la question
de l'entreposage dans l'entreprise la
question de l'entreposage qui est liée à
l' affaire de négoce puisque il s'agit
de sus prix de suspicion de fraude
suspicion de tromperie économique et
donc il y à bien un problème sur cet
entreposage et donc nous n'avons pas
levé la suspension sur cet entrepôt donc
sur la partie négoce de l'entreprise
voilà où nous en sommes aujourd'hui sur
l' enquête vétérinaire enquête
administrative enquête vétérinaire mais
surtout maintenant enquête judiciaire
puisque tous ces éléments ont été
transmis au parquet nous devons ça
encore une fois aux citoyens nous avons
pour notre part fait notre travail en
responsabilité à la justice maintenant
de pouvoir faire le sien et je le dis
moi je souhaite que les coupables
lorsqu'ils auront été désignés mis en en
responsabilité soient sévèrement punis
parce que ce type de pratique est
inacceptable
in accepte
donc enquête administrative enquête
vétérinaire enquête judiciaire mais je
veux aller un peu plus loin puisque il
s'agit d'une filière agroalimentaire qui
aujourd'hui est fragilisé par cette
crise parce que ça vient
finalement nous est une forme de crise
de confiance entre les français et leur
alimentation entre les français et les
entreprises qui produisent notre
alimentation
et c'est là dessus maintenant qu'il faut
intervenir
il ne s'agit pas simplement puis nous
l'avons fait de donner un coup d'arrêt
il faut maintenant remettre de l'ordre
alors quelle forme doit prendre cette
remise en ordre
ces deux débats et pas simplement débats
sont les actes que nous allons poser
depuis le début de la semaine dans la
suite de tout le travail que nous avons
engagées depuis des semaines des mois
mais particulièrement depuis le début de
la semaine
moi j'ai engagé une réflexion qui se
veut opérationnelle avec une visée donc
concrètes pour voir avec les entreprises
avec les industriels de de
l'agroalimentaire
comment nous pouvons aujourd'hui
répondre à cette crise de confiance est
d'abord comment nous pouvons éviter que
ce type de tromperie ne se reproduise
c'est donc d'abord la question de la
lutte contre les fraudes
première chose et lutter contre les
fraudes c'est un donner de nouveaux
outils aux entreprises pour qu'elles se
protègent elles mêmes contre ce type de
dérive ce type de pratiques et 2
améliorer ce qu'on appelle
l'autocontrôle dans les entreprises
puisque vous savez que les entreprises
sont les premières responsables des
contrôles qualité
ça c'est le travail que nous conduisons
avec les entreprises
est ce que ce sera suffisant non c'est
l'ensemble du spectre qu'il faut
aujourd'hui
traiter ça signifie donc que du point de
vue de l'information des consommateurs
nous devons être extrêmement ambitieux
et nous le sommes parce que nous sommes
volontariste vis-à-vis de l'europe
nous considérons que l'europe doit nous
protéger et davantage protéger les
consommateurs
c'est la raison pour laquelle nous avons
engagé au plan européen et nous
continuerons avec les professionnels une
action pour que ce qu'ils étaient
j'allais le dire entre guillemets dans
les tuyaux puissent être accélérées
du point de vue de l'information du
consommateur ça c'est indispensable et
benoît pourra évidemment y revenir plus
plus largement mais allons encore plus
loin
s'agit pas simplement de protéger la
filière de prendre des mesures
anti-fraude d'améliorer l'information du
consommateur tout ça s'est engagée mais
moi je veux poser de problèmes plus
largement
d'abord je considère qu' il faut mettre
en cause cette course aux bas prix
cette course effrénée aux bas prix
parce que la question qui est posée
c'est à quel est le juste prix de
l'alimentation quand vous avez un plat
de lasagnes un peu plus de 2 euros
ça pose question quand même est-ce que
c'est une juste prix pour rémunérer le
travail du transformateur pour rémunérer
le travail du producteur
cette question là elle appelle des
réponses sur le partage de la valeur
ajoutée tout au long de la filière et
elle est d'ailleurs nous avons là dessus
un travail est en cours sur ce qu'on
appelle des relations commerciales
la façon dont on organise l'equilibre le
partage cette valeur ajoutée entre
producteurs transformateurs
distributeurs
cet aspect est lié je dis bien lié à la
crise que nous traversons aujourd'hui il
nous faudra y répondre 2 au-delà de
cette course au haut bas prix pour
renouer ce lien de confiance avec les
consommateurs avec les citoyens nous
devrons aussi être extrêmement
volontariste et nous sommes sur la
qualité alimentaire au sens large et
avec le souci constant de renforcer
cette qualité pour être là où les
français nous attendent tout simplement
et j'allais dire pas simplement les
français parce que le modèle alimentaire
français qui est fait de qualité de
sécurité sanitaire est aujourd'hui un
modèle très reconnu dans le monde entier
et c'est une force pour
l'agroalimentaire français notamment à
l'international à l'export et donc nous
avons non seulement une exigence
vis-à-vis des consommateurs nous avons
un intérêt économique à renforcer
toujours cette qualité et c'est ce que
je m'emploie à faire depuis des mois
maintenant nous avons ouvert notamment
un travail sûr je m'appelle les
ingrédients dans les recettes pour faire
en sorte que l'on réponde aux attentes
de la société aujourd'hui 1 par rapport
à tous les sujets débat de société qui a
eu sur le suc les graisses le sel à
toutes ces questions nous devons
apporter réponse et c'est le travail que
j'ai anglais donc oui aujourd'hui une
crise de confiance
il faut le reconnaître est donc oui il
nous faut trouver les bonnes réponses
les réponses justes ça n'est pas
simplement une réponse mais c'est un
ensemble d'éléments qu'il nous faut
articuler
c'est la politique que j'ai engagées
pour l'agroalimentaire au nom du
gouvernement et j'ai bon espoir que nous
arrivions à de vrais résultats
là nous répondons à l'urgence mais nous
devons aussi préparer l'avenir ce matin
je réunissais le comité stratégique de
filière au mois de mai nous signerons le
contrat de filière pour l'avenir de
l'agroalimentaire un vrai plan d'action
pour l'agroalimentaire et nous
répondrons à toutes ces questions que je
viens d'évoquer
voilà ce que voulait dire monsieur le
président merci et je voudrais
simplement dire que comme vous l'avez
évoqué monsieur le ministre vous aurez
l'occasion sans doute d'être auditionné
par la commission comme une information
demandée par le groupe
udi avec son droit de tirage est donc
dans ce cadre là messieurs les ministres
ou serait sans doute renaudie sio n'est
par rapport aux démarches que vous
entamez que vous évoquez aujourd'hui est
de voir on en sera la parole est à
monsieur le noir j'ai cette demande déjà
huit maintenant neuf maintenant
qui dit mieux 10 monsieur le noir vous
laissez pas troubler eh bien je l'étais
déjà à monsieur président par vous
d'abord bien aux résidents voudrais
d'abord vous remercier d'avoir provoqué
rapidement comme moi même je l'avais
souhaité la semaine dernière en
intervenant séance publique
ici au sénat ce cette réunion et j'avais
estimé que le mieux pour que cette règle
soit rapide c'est qu'elle se tienne dans
le cas de la commission des affaires
économiques
autrement sur de commissions voire
commission denquête aurait différé les
réponses qui était attendu par les
consommateurs dans les heures et dans
les jours qui suivaient et je voudrais
remercier les ministres d'abord d'avoir
répondu à l'appel nous savons que
monsieur le foll est à l'étagé au dessus
de la vous quitté il ya peu de temps
mais je pense qu'il va nous rejoindre
bref c'est une réponse appropriée à un
vrai problème sur présente moi même un
département qui est proche de celui de
mayenne et qui est marquée par une
activité d'élevage soutenu et je dois
dire que dès que cette affaire était
connu ça a été vraiment l'affolement
dans la profession car immédiatement
c'est les consommateurs régissent la
suspicion s'est installée
d'autant que et vous avez eu raison
d'insister président l'a fait d'entrée
que dès le départ on a évoqué un risque
sanitaire
l' enquête qui a été menée assez
rapidement pu démontrer vous l'avez
souligné qu' il n'en était rien mais les
consommateurs restent quand même
dubitatif
encore aujourd'hui
et la filière bovine qui est qui est
important dans ma région en ressent
aujourd'hui les effets alors je voudrais
vous poser quelques questions d'abord
d'un point de vue strictement
ponctuelles qui a mis le doigt sur le
problème
au départ il ya bien quelqu'un qui s'est
aperçue de quelque chose il serait
intéressant de savoir fond comment la
chaîne a démarré ensuite le problème
d'étiquetage que vous avez posé est un
vrai problème quand on lit les journaux
moi je suis plutôt mais aux siens dans
ce domaine on se dit mais oui enfin
l'étiquette ne correspondait pas et
c'est le parisien qui s'appelle
aujourd'hui à paris qui en a fait la
démonstration dès le milieu de la
semaine dernière alors secondes
la deuxième question viendra d'autres
est ce qu'à un moment donné
compte tenu de l'importance du secteur
industriel concerné il n'y a pas des
vérifications qui sont faites bon parce
que évidemment derrière c'est la
troisième question est-ce que c'est pas
l'arbre qui cache la forêt la rolls
disant je ne veux surtout pas évidemment
affoler plus qu'il le faudrait les
conservateurs mais est ce que on est en
mesure de tirer toutes les conséquences
de cette affaire pour débusquer
éventuellement d'autres tentatives enfin
dernière question je rassure président
enfin vient juste de commencer et
monsieur le président laissez parler
quelqu'un qui aurait beaucoup plus de
questions à poser mais bon pour vous
être agréable je vous être plus bref que
je l'avais dans un premier temps imaginé
est ce que vous ne pensez pas que dans
l'information fait imagination
débordante continue dans dans
l'information a organisé auprès des
consommateurs moi je fonce je suis
frappée d'une chose le consommateur
aujourd'hui se laisse balader par toutes
les promotions
il est attiré par le prix je n'ai pas
qu'il est prêt à manger n'importe quoi
évidemment pas il veut être rassurée
mais l'étiquetage pour le consommateur
n'est jamais très clair
deuxièmement je pense c'est là où on
peut rebondir que c'est aussi l'occasion
de mettre en évidence que la qualité est
au rendez vous chez un grand nombre de
producteurs notamment ceux qui vendent
directement ceux qui ne passent pas par
ces chaînes que vous avez décrite et
caetera et je voudrais que dans le
contrat de filière que vous êtes en
train de travailler avec la profession
et puisse y avoir une place plus
importante qui soit faite aux petits
producteurs
merci je vois que les président du
groupe d'études d'élevage et du groupe
d'études économie agricole et
alimentaire nous ont rejoints si lee
l'un ou l'autre désire prendre la parole
lors donnera la priorité est évidemment
oui merci monsieur le président juste
une petite question parce que tout
d'abord je vous prie de bien vouloir
nous excuser d'être en retard nous
étions à une précédente
c'est un débat ce qui traitait d'abord
des de l'avenir des territoires ruraux
donc là la question qui nous vient qui
me vient à l'esprit c'est celle de la
confiance puisque on a vraiment le on
est vraiment devant un cas de figure
particulier où ce sont des échanges qui
sont basés sur un système de confiance
et cette confiance vient d'être rompu
quels sont les princes les systèmes qui
peuvent être mis en place pour justement
éviter ce type de dérives et pouvoir
maintenir ce ces échanges en toute
légalité et d'autre part la question qui
vient ensuite c'est qu'elle peut être la
répercussion sur la viande bovine qui
avait déjà bien du mal à émerger suite
un certain nombre de crises donc on a
bien l'impression que dans l'esprit des
consommateurs il ya un amalgame qui fait
en dix ans même s'il n'y a pas de
problème sanitaire
à la clé dans ce qui vient de se passer
mais c'est vraiment quelles sont les
répercussions possibles sur la viande
bovine et sur les éleveurs qui ont déjà
de grandes difficultés
voilà les deux questions que je souhaite
est posée merci nico le ministre vient
de nous donner une partie des réponses
mais il se fera un plaisir de te
répondre monsieur bailly président du
groupe élevage merci président j'étais
quand même très très surpris de
l'ampleur cette tricherie on pourrait
dire c'est pour ça qu'on a fait un
communiqué parce que sam encore jeanne
est sans doute la crédibilité bien de ce
que les gens mangent
surtout qu en étant producteur on est un
petit peu choqué qu'on en arrive là et
que par le passé on a pu suivre déjà
avec la commission économique
il ya quelques années un peu la
traçabilité de produits rouges étaient
même allés depuis les abattoirs jusqu'en
dans les usines de transformation et que
j'avais presque pu constater que
pratiquement dernier m'a morceaux de la
bête on avait la traçabilité de
justement de ce bétail et j'avais
presque pu constater que du bétail
partait de notre ferme c'est arrivé près
d'orléans fin où il avait été
transformée qu'il était consommée chez
mcdonald's j'avais pu constater aussi à
ma grande parce que mam avait mis bien
défaut parce que j'avais un petit peu
critique vis-à-vis des mcdo qui m'avait
invité à aller sur place il me dit
monsieur bailly vous prenez enfin
regarder la référence et on vous dit
qu'à 5 heures de l'après midi on vous
dit andrade en mousse ou le blé a été
exploité alors personnellement je n'y
croyais pas mais j'ai été obligé de
constater que verse 17h30 coup de
téléphone me dit monsieur bailly le blé
alors que vous avez mangé vient de tels
endroits
donc personnellement toujours incrédule
pourront pas dire le lendemain j'ai
téléphoné à l'agriculteur qui était tout
surpris que moi ça se faisait
comment ça se faisait que sénateur
pouvais l'appeler
alors c'est vrai qu'ils savaient pas
qu'elles allaient chez mcdo mais m'a
bien donné la référence de la
coopérative est la parcelle est le jour
qui l'a moissonnait les intrants qu'elle
avait mis alors moi j'étais vraiment est
sage parce que je peux vous dire agir et
j'y croyais c'est pour cela qu'en
l'histoire de cette viande de cheval moi
elle m'a vraiment
surpris parce que je croyais je croyais
vraiment par le travail qu'on avait pu
faire qui avait vraiment une traçabilité
des pros des produits alors ma question
est toute simple ou est vraiment la
tricherie à quel moment on a dit et bien
un endroit un endroit que c'est le
moment de maubeuge est devenu cheval c
est ce qu sortie de l'abattoir
c'est un cas l'entreprise c'est ma
question si vous voici monsieur courteau
merci monsieur le merci monsieur le
président 1 il est impératif que la
justice passe et là je crois que nous
sommes tous d'accord sur ce point
2 je reconnais je m'adresse à messieurs
les ministres que vous avez
effectivement réagi avec je vous cite
rapidité fermeté et discernement
discernement joueurs le mot est
important
cela dit moi je voudrais me réjouir avec
mon collègue marcel rainaud sénateur de
l'aude que l'entreprise audoise
aujourd'hui puissent préparer sombre
démarrage même partiellement
je me réjouis pour les 300 salariés
je m'en réjouis pour les sous traitants
de ce secteur mais également pour le
tissu économique local départemental et
régional
en effet les coupables ne sont pas à
rechercher du côté des salariés
cela dit j'espère que les opérateurs
maintenant conserveront leur confiance
dans cette filière particulièrement
fragilisées sud ministre et dans les
industries de la ville de castelnaudary
elle le mérite ces industries je vous
rappelle que qu'à saint lary est la
capitale mondiale du cassoulet question
difficile question délicate comment
répondre à cette crise de confiance
comment faire pour maintenir une unité
de production de ses 300 salariés dans
le contexte actuel et alors que le nom
de l'entreprise est entachée
et qu'il y a dommage de réputation voilà
je crois l'autre problème et il n'est
pas secondaire
et enfin dernière question monsieur le
président comment à l'avenir éviter de
telles situations
surtout si l'on sait que les effectifs
de la direction de la concurrence ont
été tout particulièrement réduit ces
dernières années
vous avez parlé d'auto contrôle monsieur
le ministre mais dispose-t-on vraiment
des moyens suffisants pour exercer des
contrôles normaux et systématique
plus encore que nécessaire que l'auto
contrôle lui-même
merci je vais peut-être prendre encore
trois prises de parole et les ministres
répondront dans cette première salve de
questions monsieur césar
oui merci monsieur le président moi je
voudrais féliciter les ministres par
rapport leur diligence et aussi leur
efficacité
il faut et gaziers des sur la dgccrf
pires n 1 qui ont bien travaillé mais
les ministres ont pris position et je
voudrais les féliciter
c'est pas mal habitude mais aujourd'hui
je tenais à le faire publiquement jeu je
voudrais ajouter dans le cas de lehman
en gt les rapporteurs nous avons nous
avions volet très important sur la
nutrition santé
nous avons organisé et à la maison de la
chimie à peu de temps sur le foll
étaient le ministre le foll étaient
présents donc des colloques sur cette
nutrition santé est l'un des six it est
justement d'avancé par rapport à la
qualité des produits
la question qu'on peut se poser
aujourd'hui c'est comment peut-on
harmoniser cette législation française
au niveau de tous les pays d'europe des
27 pays d'europe
car les roumains aujourd'hui sont en
cause et c'est sûr qu'ils n'ont pas les
mêmes la même traçabilité que chez nous
et c'est important de le souligner et
surtout d'en trouver les moyens
roland courteau a posé à l'instant le
problème des plaintes en justice et le
ministre a dit tout à l'heure les
ministres ont dit qu'ils avaient une
plainte au parquet été déposé mais quand
est ce que cette plainte va être traités
qu'à toulouse on connaissant la vitesse
de traitement des dossiers par la
justice française
on peut se dire que de report en report
de deux cours d'appel un cour d'appel de
cassation en cassation
ça pourrait durer très longtemps donc il
est urgent que le parquet puisse prendre
une décision et surtout communiquer
communiqués pour rassurer les
consommateurs sur la décision qui sera
prise par rapport donc assez à ces
fraudes
j'ajouterai qu'il faut maintenant
essayer de trouver les solutions pour le
futur pour confirmer cette traçabilité
que nous souhaitons tous par rapport aux
consommateurs cette traçabilité est
importante
est-ce qu'il faut généraliser des puces
donc au niveau des animaux les puces que
vous connaissez bien ou en particulier
aux oreilles et s'il n'y a pas de trafic
de fait par rapport donc à ces puces qui
seraient mises en place donc là aussi je
crois qu'il faut qu'au niveau de
l'europe nous prenions des décisions
importantes par rapport donc à cette
recherche de traçabilité
autre point et ça a été abordée est
aussi concerné la belle nous souhaitons
que les labels label rouge
le lésé gp se développent et tout cela
il faut un soutien par exemple par
rapport aux groupements de producteurs
qui sont dans notre pays très important
et qui font d'une très bonne qualité
je terminerai en disant aujourd'hui les
éleveurs bovins risque de payer les pots
cassés de cette affaire il faut faire
très attention être très prudent et
surtout communiquer sur ce que vous avez
fait messieurs les ministres par rapport
donc la qualité de nos produits
merci si juste une petite remarque mon
collègue césar ce serait sans doute pas
une puce mais une étiquette rfid
monsieur bourquin oui quelques mots pour
pour compléter ce qu'on dit mes
collègues
la filière agroalimentaire c'est 140
milliards de chiffre d'affaires
c'est dix mille entreprises et ses 400
mille salariés fews avoir ça en tête
lorsqu'on aborde ces questions parce
qu'il ya faut l'aborder avec le recul et
l'importance de ce secteur
et cette question je pense a été bien
gérée par le gouvernement
pourquoi parce que il ya eu la volonté
discernement pour ne pas jeter
l'opprobre sur la filière ça c'est très
important
la deuxième chose prend toutes ses
responsabilités par rapport à une fraude
manifeste inacceptable qui peut porter
préjudice à l'ensemble de la filière et
ça qu'il fallait travailler avec
discernement
l'agrément devait être levé et ensuite
faire toute la lumière
faire en sorte qu'il y ait que la
justice aille jusqu'au bout
alors chers collègues et messieurs les
ministres après vos deux interventions
je pense que il ya deux questions qui
vont pour rétablir la confiance
la première question c'est celle de la
traçabilité
cette traçabilité elle doit être réel et
faire en sorte que lorsque il y a un
produit qui est étiqueté comment il doit
être respecté et il faut le dire la
dgccrf a un rôle fondamental à jouer et
on sait que on parle beaucoup
d'économies on parle mais il faut donner
à ce corps d'état la possibilité de
remplir ses fonctions parce qu'elle a
été vraiment est là elle a joué
effectivement tout son rôle dans ce
domaine la deuxième chose mais la
question va venir et benoît hamon va
nous présenter dans quelques temps une
loi sur la question de de la
consommation en général la question de
la transparence est une question
essentielle
si on veut de la confiance traçabilité
et transparence sont absolument
indissociables parce qu'on parle de
l'alimentation aujourd'hui et c'est pas
un produit comme les autres
on touche à l'humain on touche à la
santé
il y en a qui disent est le premier
médicament puis ils ont raison on touche
à l'humain et sur ces questions là si on
veut rétablir une confiance et comme
c'était dit tout à l'heure si on veut
faire en sorte que ce secteur qui est un
des plus exportateurs alors que notre
problème c'est d'exportation et bien il
ne faut pas essayer de copier le bas de
gamme
faire en sorte que nous produisions des
bons on se fera toujours battre par
d'autres pays sur ce bas de gamme par
contre la montée en gamme la
transparence la réputation de la cuisine
française
la réputation d'agriculture françaises
doivent être portés haut et ça je crois
que si on arrive à faire cela on aura su
gérer ce qu'on appelle une crise et
faire en sorte que en même temps on
développe on continue à développer
l'agro alimentaire je crois que la
politique de filières qui était abordé
tout à l'heure est vraiment une
politique fondamentale pour faire en
sorte que on donne une direction la
direction c'est la qualité c'est la
transparence c'est la traçabilité voilà
je pense qu'il va leurs deux gros
propres dossiers qui nous arrive un de
l'europe l'europe vient d'autoriser
malgré le vote de deux commandes de
députés français l'autorisation des
farines animales pour les poissons
c'est pas une bonne décision faut le
dire beaucoup de de commandes de députés
français ont voté contre
et la deuxième chose la question des ogm
c'est des questions qui vont arriver et
vous verrez un cette crise la veille
dans une crise des fois on trouve on
sait qu'une crise et nous amène à pu
repenser les choses comme auparavant
la question de la qualité de la
transparence et la traçabilité vont est
au coeur de l'organisation de la filière
et du développement de la filière merci
mon cher collègue madame le mur oui
merci monsieur le président rapporteur
de la loi lme justement mais vous aimez
bien le rappeler
et messieurs les ministres l'événement
qui nous préoccupe a fait l'objet d'un
véritable emballement médiatique qu'on
peut je crois jugé un peu excessif parce
que même s'il s'agit d'une fraude vous
l'avez rappelé les uns et les autres il
n'y a pas eu de problème sanitaire et je
crois que il faut pas hésiter à le
redire et à le marteler
parce qu'on a l'impression de se
retrouver en pleine crise de la vache
folle et on a l'impression que la viande
de cheval tout à coup c'est du poison
alors que c'est pas du tout le cas moi
il me semble qu'il faut le dire et le
redire et 7
cet événement pose je crois la question
de la complexité des circuits
là aussi on a l'impression de se
retrouver au même moment que la crise
financière et que le problème de cette
complexité des circuits a complètement
échapper aux autorités
alors à ce titre compte tenu de la place
qu'occupe la france en europe au titre
de l'agroalimentaire messieurs les
ministres est ce que vous avez les
moyens de peser sur une simplification
de ces circuits ou en tout cas une
meilleure connaissance de deux circuits
dont on parle si pour équilibrer les
prises de parole monsieur d'aunis en
arrêtera là pour des réponses des deux
ministres d'abord merci je voudrais tout
d'abord aussi à mon tour souligné la
qualité de la réponse gouvernementale et
particulièrement des ministres sur une
réponse proportionnée et coordonner ce
que disait mon collègue césar me paraît
tout à fait juste sur un dossier qui est
délicat et effectivement il ya eu un
emballement médiatique
par ailleurs
je crois que l'entrée qui vient d'être
soulignée par le ministre allemand
concernant l'analyse de la filière
certes mais aussi des périphériques est
fondamental dans pour poser les termes
du débat vis-à-vis de nos concitoyens
quatre questions rapides la première
concernant la pertinence de la
traçabilité est ce que vous ne penserez
pas souhaitable que très rapidement un
message positif soit délivré là dessus
parce que si toute cette procédure
judiciaire aujourd'hui est en cours si
cette fraude a pu être avérés c'est
aussi la vérification de l'efficacité
d'un système de traçabilité et il serait
peut-être temps peut-être que là il ya
une petite difficulté aujourd'hui à le
faire mais que rapidement il ce message
très positif qu'ils soient portés par
les uns par les autres deuxième question
ne voyez vous pas un risque à ce qu'il y
ait ne peut que l'once nous cédions un
renforcement qui pourrait être excessif
de mesures de protection qui pourrait se
retourner contre la filière elle même je
prends juste un exemple pour les
éleveurs
dauvin
en élevage extensif la puce donc parler
notre collègue césar est extrêmement
complexe et coûteuse
quelles sont rfid ou quelques
technologies que ce soit avec en oeuvre
et par ailleurs pourrait se retourner
même contre et ça va être ma troisième
troisième question contre des circuits
courts et favoriser des importations ou
là il y aurait une traçabilité externe
mais avec des transports des bilans
carbone à la fin extrêmement défavorable
et est-ce qu'il n'y aurait pas là une
sensibilisation que nous pourrions faire
sur une sensibilisation de nos
concitoyens aux circuits courts et une
incitation aussi dans ces industries de
transformation à usage de circuits
courts
à travers cette promotion est enfin le
dernier point dans la loi à venir sur la
consommation
il paraît important qu'il puisse y avoir
un volet sur la composition des des
produits avec les ingrédients qui la
composent
et là dessus il apparaît quand même que
nous sommes actuellement un peu léger
sur ce volet-là bien merci
mich sur l'éthique cash complet des
produits élaborés ça pose un certain
nombre de problèmes s'ils proviennent
cayenne c'est lent ou ailleurs mais s'il
faut tout mettre sur l'étiquette je
pense que la fois trop d'information tué
l'information mais pour l'essentiel il
faut savoir partager les choses
monsieur le ministre allemand vous avez
le premier la parole
alors merci à vous je vais essayer de
de brefs et laisser tout ce qui relève
de la compétence du miz agriculture et
du ministre de l'agro alimentaire à
leurs soins un mot sur ce qui relève de
la traçabilité la législation européenne
et le héros drogue conso bon on est
devant la nécessité aujourd'hui de
revoir règlement qui le règlement
européen un co tech qui lie à justifier
que nous nous rendions avec comme le
ministre de l'agriculture à bruxelles la
semaine dernière dans une position
nouvelle moins isolés que nous n'avons
pu l'être dans le passé
en tout cas avec le royaume uni à nos
côtés pour demander ce qu'on accélère la
remise d'un rapport par la commission en
ce sens pour poser la question de la
traçabilité de la viande cette fois ci
qui entrent en ligne de compte dans la
fabrication des plats préparés des
produits transformés de telle manière
que sur cette traçabilité figure
l'origine lieu de naissance le
d'abattage lieux d'élevage de l'animal
ce qui sera un progrès mais vous l'avez
dit plusieurs d'entre vous le sénateur
bailly la très bien d'illustrer la trabi
c'est monsieur le sénateur césar aussi
la traçabilité la bien fonctionné c'est
parce que les instruments étaient là
quand 48 ans remonte jusqu'à la roumanie
en passant par chypre et les pays-bas et
de traders donc je peux vous dire que ce
qu'ils avaient commencé en tout cas un
seul en réalité puisque c'est le même
que l'étiquette elle commence déjà à
changer aux pays bas et que ce que nous
avons nous vu et constaté sur la foi des
déclarations et et des pièces produites
par le ministre de l'agriculture ou même
que nous avons rencontrés avec stéphane
le foll
à bruxelles c'est qu'en roumanie devait
vendre du cheval pour du cheval mais
qu'à la fin nous on achète du cheval
pour du beurre et quand vont du cheval
produits peuvent nous en tout cas
des entreprises françaises cette
traçabilité l'a bien fonctionné est ce
que cette crise nous dit est mise
l'agriculture d'une bonne formule avait
résumé c'est que nous sommes moins de
vent aujourd'hui la nécessité de nous
protéger grâce à ces instruments là
contre un risque sanitaire
bactériologique que face à une tromperie
économique qui peut mettre qui m'arrange
coin des comportements qui sont des
comportements évidemment minoritaires
nous le répéterons mais les
comportements qui même si on multiplie
les policiers les gendarmes on
n'arrivera jamais empêché qui est des
voleurs et des tricheurs donc la
question qui nous est posée
collectivement c'est outre les progrès
qu'il faut faire sur la traçabilité pour
ce qui concerne les produits transformés
hélas il y a aujourd'hui des avantages à
favoriser à valoriser la viande bovine
française celle que nous faisons d'un
malin bien on a quand même quelques
acquis à valoriser outre les progrès que
l'on peut réaliser dans ce domaine là il
faut aujourd'hui penser la façon dont le
secteur se protègent du risque de
tromperie économique et comment on
adapte notre réponse à cela je me
permets de le dire parce que moi je n'ai
apprécié et c'était pas
démocratie c'est pas tous les jours
moi j'ai apprécié que d'anciens
ministres du gouvernement précédent mon
prédécesseur salue la façon dont le
gouvernement avait traité cette question
là donc je le dis j'ai apprécié
évidemment à juste titre le le les
remarques du sénateur césar c'est parce
qu'on est là dans des sujets où on voit
bien que l'opinion publique par très
très vite se mobilisent très très vite
parfois sur des faisceaux d'informations
qui sont d'ailleurs et les journalistes
font leur travail donne que les infos
qu'ils ont qu'ils ont sous la main mais
on peut très vite transformé ce qui
relevait d'une tromperie économiques ont
une crise sanitaire ou une panique
sanitaire majeur et et il a fallu
intervenir
la décision du miz de l'agriculture
c'était celle-là
la levée de l'agrément sanitaire c'était
le principe de précaution de telle
manière qu'on pouvait dire il ya
peut-être tromperie économique chez
spanghero
mais quoi que vous mangiez qui soit issu
de chez eux vous n'allez pas tomber
malade à cause de cela et c'était
important de dire qu'on n'était pas là
dans une crise sanitaire et je veux
saluer ce la conséquence pour le projet
de loi consommation
première chose aujourd'hui les peines
encourues pour tromperie économique et
les niveaux d'amande
ils sont pour une personne physique de
37000 quelques euros
deux ans d'emprisonnement mais 37000
quelques euros pour une personne morale
ça se monte à 187 milles je crois euros
ce qui au regard du bénéfice réalisé on
peut considérer que le montant de la
pénalité est quand même par rapport à 1
550 mille euros en six mois à sebha bon
le quantum double je crois dès lors
qu'on constate qu'il ya une modification
de la composition de l'aliment mais je
ne crois pas que nous soyons dans cette
situation où nous puissions faire la
démonstration qu'il y aura une
modification de la composition
cela étant dit moi je réfléchirai
dans le projet de loi consommation à
cette question
aujourd'hui du conte hommes tant sur le
montant de la pénalité que sur les
peines d'emprisonnement pour qu'elles
soient plus dissuasive qu'elle ne l'est
aujourd'hui
première remarque deuxième remarque et
je vous nous mais la dhr intra 20 des
travaux pratiques auxquelles il va
falloir se livrer avant le projet de loi
consommation
nous sommes là dans un contentieux de
masse économique qui tombent sous le
coup d'une action de groupe
si jamais nous la voterons cette année
dans le projet de loi consommation d'une
action de groupe qui pourrait être
portée par des consommateurs
derrière une association de
consommateurs contre l'entreprise
responsable de ce préjudice économique
parce que ce qui se passe aujourd'hui
c'est qu'on rappelle des produits qu'on
les retire mais il ya des gens qui vont
manger du cheval à la place du boeuf et
acheter des barquettes de viande
préparée de cheval on n'y a pas de
viande de boeuf pendant plusieurs mois
ce que pour vous avez été quelques temps
célibataires ou habiter ou fait la
cuisine tout seul vous en avez mangé des
surgelés et je suis sûr qu'il ya
quelques spécialistes des plats préparés
et d'autres lasagnes etc
d'aucun préjudice et je veux des normes
je donne pas d nous si je montre là
peut-être qu'il ya des spécialistes du
micro ondes et des plats préparés en
tout cas tous les élus ont fait ça un
jour j'imagine mon autre cas moi je les
fais un bon voilà donc jour d'os mais ce
que je sais c'est que il ya on ça peut
tomber sous le coup d'une action de
groupe ce sujet sera discuté dans le
cadre du projet de loi consommation
il devra nous amener à examiner comment
aujourd'hui les consommateurs se
protègent mieux contre ce type de
préjudice économique de masquer le
niveau de la réparation qui peut être
décidée par le juge insiste sur un point
que sur l'évolution d'un règlement du
règlement 1 co c'est l'europe ce qui n'a
pas empêché la g serait la parole à mes
collègues sur la filière agroalimentaire
élèves et l'autocontrôle un point parce
que la question c'est est la toute
première question qui a trouvé quoi
c'est en réalité un autocontrôle réalisé
par industriels sur la viande en
l'occurrence findus qui a déterminé au
tour de la
cependant durant le mois de janvier la
présence de viande de cheval et le
processus et ainsi enclenchée et quand
il est remonté jusqu'à comme hygiène et
que comme hygiène a saisi les autorités
en l'occurrence les autorités
luxembourgeoises ont été signés saisie
par les britanniques qui nous ont saisis
nous pourquoi parce que comme il l est
un groupe français même si l'usiné tant
ils sont bons et que comme il l a elle
même saisi la ddpp ou la ddcspp je ne
sais pas trop la moselle c'est ainsi
nous avons été alertés mais qu'il me
soit permis de dire je crois que nous
avons été bien inspiré cette année de
sanctuary 0 loi de finances les
effectifs de la dgccrf
parce que là dessus on voit tout cas
l'importance de faire la distinction
on peut se consacrer tous à la
modernisation de l'action publique à la
meilleure efficacité de service public
mais y est je pense et je vous donne ma
conviction qui a des limites et la
polyvalence des comptes de des agents
sur le terrain on doit contrôler la
chaîne du froid on doit vérifier ce qui
se passe dans l'agroalimentaire contre
les fils la sûreté des lois des loisirs
pour enfants
il ya aujourd'hui faire des enquêtes sur
le cybercommerce une information 9
milliards d'euros d'achats sur internet
à noël par les français vous imaginez le
nombre de mauvaises surprises qu'il ya
eu dans le cadre de ces achats faits sur
des sites qui étaient pas forcément en
france ce qui suppose d'adapter aussi
notre notre contrôle et nos instruments
de lutte contre cette triche à ces
nouvelles pratiques commerciales
donc il faudra sans doute
se pencher aussi sur ce sujet là les
moyens qui sont ceux de la dgccrf sur le
terrain parce qu'en l'occurrence je vais
donner à l'assemblée je vous le donne
dans l'aude les effectifs de la dgccrf
sont passés de 16 à 10 en raison de
l'arrêt at heller gbp est de 43 à 20 en
moselle on a donc bon en même temps je
veux pas en faire un débat puisque je
dis c'est que maintenant qu'on a ça
regardons ensemble comment
collectivement on peut essayer de faire
en sorte il d'administration c'est
valable pour les services vétérinaires
comme pour le contrôle économique
dispose des moyens de faire face aux
risques qui existent ou sanitaires ou
économique bon j'ai pas répondu à tout
le monde j'ai essayé de rassembler ma
réponse de façon à ce qu'elle puisse
embrasser une partie de vos
préoccupations
oui ah oui j'ai oublié de te dire en ce
moment même la question est est ce que
ça va aller vite
je crois qu'en ce moment même d'après
les bribes d'informations que j'ai
leclerc est en lien avec le sc ne
réalise les premières perquisitions et
auditions à spanghero et dans
probablement qu'il y aura je crois je
suis pas gendarme et un stand de
l'audition un peu à peu poussé
voilà donc en tout cas je ne sais pas
quel le temps que prendra la procédure
le parquet n'a pas été lents en tout cas
diligenter les services de localités du
sn 2 pour prolonger les premières
conclusions qu'elle était parvenue la
dgccrf jeudi soir dan et monsieur le
ministre la parole à monsieur guillaume
garot merci monsieur le président alors
pour essayer de présenter des réponses
synthétique à toutes ces questions qui
sont convergentes vers quelques sujets
phares d'abord pour disons que enquête
administrative enquête vétérinaire
enquête judiciaire tout ça se succèdent
une telle façon que nous puissions
garantir aux français qu'eux
la réponse sera très fermes pour les
raisons que nous avons évoquées c'est
inacceptable c'est scandaleux et donc ça
ne doit pas se reproduire
mais une fois qu'on a dit ça qu'est ce
que nous faisons pour changer les choses
comment nous réformons l'ensemble du
système c'est le débat qui est devant
nous et c'est là dessus que nous devons
avancer prendre des mesures et trancher
alors je le redis pour en quelques mots
pour ceux qui n'étaient pas là au début
de notre audition jeudi matin nous
recevons au ministère de l'agriculture
et de l'agroalimentaire les
professionnels et sans attendre nous
travaillons avec eux à des mesures
concrètes tout ne sera pas actée dès
jeudi matin
ça se fait pas sur un claquement de
doigts il faut du sérieux
il faut valider des procédures bien
évidemment mais nous allons de façon
extrêmement nettes poser un cadre et
tracer un cap
ce qui veut dire que nous allons
travailler sur le renforcement de ce que
l'on appelle les procédures d'auto
contrôle un chat
entreprise ou pouvoir réaliser ses
autocontrôles mais soyons un peu précis
autant contrôle sur ce qu'elle produit
auto contrôle sur la relation avec ses
fournisseurs
c'est capital
bon 2 comment protéger davantage en tout
cas mieux protéger les entreprises
donnons des outils nouveaux entreprises
pour qu'elles puissent garantir une
nouvelle forme de protection c'est ce
que nous ferons aussi jeudi matin que la
filière se protège mieux contre toutes
les dérives ou les pratiques
frauduleuses qui pourraient surgir
il ya un filet dont l'émail aujourd'hui
sont parfois trop lâches et donc il faut
resserrer les mailles de ce filet 3
toujours à l'ordre du jour de la réunion
jeudi matin l'information du
consommateur
vous savez que ce n'est pas simplement
un problème franco français que la
dimension est à l'évidence européenne
mais nous devons être volontariste nous
devons être locomotive en europe pour
passer un nouveau cap propre à ces
nouvelles étapes de telle sorte que les
citoyens français et européens puissent
être parfaitement rassurés sur ce qu'il
y a dans leur assiette
alors aujourd'hui vous le savez je le
redis pour celles et ceux qui ne
seraient pas parfaitement éclairé sur
ces sujets la mention de l'origine est
obligatoire pour les viandes fraîches
vous achetez un steak
vous savez d'où il vient c'est ce que
disait un de vous tout à l'heure voilà
nous savons précisément dans quelle
élevage la bête a été élevé nous savons
où elle a été abattue et nous savons
comment elle arrive dans l'assiette pour
les plats préparés
vous n'êtes pas de mention obligatoire
de l'origine
donc là il ya une zone d'incertitude
de confusion possible une zone qu'il
nous faudra éclairé c'est ce combat que
nous portons au plan européen
alors disons les choses ce n'est pas
chose simple techniquement parce que
comme le disait le président raoul
il faut que l'étiquette pour les
consommateurs restent néanmoins lisible
compréhensible accessible un et nous
devons trouver une mesure équilibrée
mais qui permettent de marquer une
nouvelle étape de la transparence
vis-à-vis du consommateur
2e série de question qui a été posée
c'est celle des circuits 1
on sent des circuits on voit des
circuits complexes qui sont nature à
amener de l'opacité
ce que nous voyons c'est que il y à du
négoce il y à des traders et ses traders
ce que nous savons c'est qu'ils ne sont
pas soumis précisément aux mêmes
obligations que les autres acteurs de la
chaîne alimentaire
la prochaine étape c'est de donner un
cadre beaucoup plus rigoureux beaucoup
plus exigeants à l'exercice de la
profession de trader
celle sorte que y compris sur la partie
sanitaire ils soient soumis à des
obligations très strictes
c'est ce à quoi travaille stéphane le
foll donc sur les circuits donner
davantage de transparence et faire en
sorte que chacun soit soumis à des
obligations très strictes
enfin sur les messages positifs que nous
pourrions valoriser c'est vrai il faut
le dire et le redire
1 il n'ya ça n'est pas une crise
sanitaire
2 ça n'est pas non plus une crise de la
traçabilité au contraire la traçabilité
a parfaitement fonctionné
simplement il ya eu triche il ya une
suspicion de
fraude donc c'est là dessus que nous
devons travailler et c'est ce que nous
faisons dans l'urgence et pour l'avenir
alors on dit aussi sur ces messages
positifs mais il faudrait valoriser les
circuits courts très bien faisons le
mais ne le faisons pas au détriment de
l'ensemble des filières de
l'agroalimentaire ne valorisons pas un
aspect de la production de la
transformation plutôt agroalimentaire au
détriment des industries
agroalimentaires parce que je vous le
dis mesdames messieurs sénateurs ce sont
les emplois de nos territoires et donc
l'exigence que nous portons que nous
devons porter pour la qualité
1 ce que je vous disais lutter qualité
alimentaire sécurité sanitaire c'est
bien évidemment une exigence qui vaut
pour l'ensemble du modèle alimentaire
français quelles que soient les
producteurs quelles que soient les
transformateurs c'est essentiel de
porter ce message là en tout cas c'est
celui je porterai merci monsieur le
ministre le foll rajouter grand chose
sur tout ce qui a été dit ce que je
crois que ça a été suffisamment
exhaustif par rapport aux gens je à ce
qui a été fait sur la question sur la
question sanitaire la nécessité qu'il y
avait de prendre les décisions qu'on a
prises pour faire en sorte qu'on y voie
clair et qu'on rassure tout le monde
moi ce que je voulais dire maintenant
c'est que y'a une perquisition
ça va sortir l'un c'est parti donc vous
avez été les premiers informés
et en même temps il ya aussi des
responsabilités de chacun des acteurs et
en particulier de ceux qui dirigent les
entreprises qui sont concernés ce que
rétablir la confiance
c'est en partie notre responsabilité
mais si au sein de l'entreprise montre
pas que par rapport à ce qui s'est passé
on en tire un certain nombre de
conclusions sur un certain nombre de
responsables
c'est sûr qu'après faut pas venir parce
que je sais ce qu'ils savaient dans
cette histoire on prend des décisions
ont dit c'est bien vous prenez décision
vu dès qu'on a suspendu c'était vous
avez mis 300 salariés au chômage après
ça va être un oui mais c'est la
confiance qui est perdu et puis et qui
est responsable toujours la même
histoire
là il ya une responsabilité nous on a
assumé nos responsabilités
et quand vous avez à l'échelle
européenne une crise européenne que vous
allez mercredi dernier à bruxelles avec
la présidence irlandaise
mon ami britannique qui lui en plus a
non seulement l'histoire findus mais des
abattoirs qui ont abattu des chevaux
avec des files buta zone qu'on a
retrouvé d'ailleurs key qui nous a été
notifié dès qu'on a là dessus on les a
détruits mais enfin c'est une crise et
j'espère que on continue nous avec les
tests adn et au niveau de la commission
ce sera poursuivie mais si on apprend
que avec 7,7 viande de cheval au delà
même de la filière qu'on connaît
peut-être d'autres et je l'espère pas
mais voyez un peu ce que ça représente
donc on a intérêt d'assumer nos
responsabilités de manière claire ferme
et ça peut coûter et chaque décision est
prise et à chaque fois mesurée à l'aune
des deux enjeux pourquoi on n'a pas
retiré l'agrément et on l'a suspendu
c'est que si on retire l agrément là
pour leur donner
ça prend plusieurs semaines le suspense
était le moyen de pouvoir y voir clair
sur la question des sanitaires et
franchement le directeur le dégel et
puis mon conseiller au cabinet ils sont
là tout le week-end à partir du jeudi
conférence de presse de benoît hamon
on envoie la brigade de vendredi ce
travail tout le week-end et le dimanche
soir les premiers éléments on les avait
déjà lundi matin il y avait un compte
rendu dans quête qui était très clair et
qui nous permettait de prendre des
décisions en partie sur un certain
nombre d'activités
je le dis aussi ici devant cette
commission vendredi on peut rendra
public le rapport complet qui aura été
fait par les services vétérinaires sur
place complet la transparence sera
totale tout ce qui a été fait tout ce
qui a été vu tout ce qui a été contrôlée
comme ça chacun saura
sur quoi nous appuyons pour prendre des
décisions et à chaque fois ces décisions
sont mesurés avec la double
responsabilité qui est la nôtre une
responsabilité vis-à-vis des
consommateurs vis-à-vis de l'ensemble de
la filière vis-à-vis de l'élevage et
puis il y avait aussi cette
responsabilité liée localement à une
entreprise qui était dans la difficulté
mais je le redis nhs devant vous il ya
aussi des responsabilités dans
l'entreprise
parce que les étiquettes elle se change
pas tout seul et il ya des gens qui
voient là donc il ya ça aussi
bon je voulais vous le dire autrement au
niveau européen ce qu'on va faire c'est
sur deux points un peu plus technique
est à la fois la question de la
traçabilité de l'étiquetage
on a demandé à la commission européenne
d'accélérer un rapport qui devait être
produit à la fin de l'année pour qu'elle
le fasse avant l'été avec l'objectif de
renforcer la traçabilité
deuxième point on a aussi un texte sur
les normes en particulier sur les normes
liées à la viande dans lesquelles il y
avait de normes et un certain nombre de
viande et pas toutes les viandes
on va faire changer et étendre
l'ensemble du système en y intégrant
d'autres ou viande en particulier la
viande de cheval
lafarge changer ça on va regarder ce que
disait guillaume aussi sur le fait
qu'aujourd'hui à des agréments qui sont
donnés à toute personne qui stockent de
la viande mais les traders qui n'ont
stocke pas nos aucun l'agrément
n'importe qui à sénateurs aujourd'hui
qu'ils aient envie de faire de l'achat
et de la vente peut avoir un bureau à
l'ordinateur et mettre quelqu'un à faire
du trading
ça peut pas durer la forte on les repère
quand les classes et qu'ils aient aussi
une responsabilité pas les sénateurs
ceux qui font du commerce mais sur ce
que vous vous êtes des élus de la nation
et en conséquence de quoi ces électeurs
qui voulaient donne la responsabilité
voilà ce que je voulais vous dire on a
travaillé en commun sur la question des
services
dès que je suis arrivé on avait à
réfléchir dans le cadre budgétaire que
vous savez aux priorités qu'on fixe et
et dans le ministère de l'agriculture de
l'agroalimentaire de la forêt il ya deux
priorités ont été fixées
saignements ricol et les services
vétérinaires et on est en train de
travailler avec les syndicats sur la
définition d'un plan stratégique pour le
ministère de l'agriculture dans lequel
on intègre la question des services
vétérinaires parce que bon et comme l'a
dit mon nom en revient pas il ya eu des
suppressions de postes maintenant il
faut qu'on s'organise pour que le
contrôle de l'état soit extrêmement
fermes claires et permettent d'assurer
la sécurité à la fois sanitaire pour ce
qui nous concerne mais globalement sur
les tromperies à tous les français merci
monsieur le ministre j'ai encore neuf
demandes de parole et donc vous avez
bien compris que si on pouvait condenser
les questions ce serait pas plus mal
monsieur dubois
merci président je me joins au collet
qui considère que c'est que cette crise
est plutôt bien géré ceci étant dit moi
j'ai exprime une inquiétude parce que
gérard bailly l'a dit très clairement
tout à l'heure le raid dans notre pays
la traçabilité d'une efficacité
j'allais dire presque redoutable et donc
ça a plutôt bien fonctionné
alors de grâce de grâce pas de normes
supplémentaires sur la traçabilité et en
particulier pour nos agriculteurs parce
que eux
s'il ya une boucle qui se décroche et
d'une bête réinstaller dans une pâture
ils sont contrôlés donc je le dis ici
avec beaucoup de simplicité on est face
à une fraude
et moi j'ai tendance à rejoindre le
ministre amon rê face aux fraudes eh
bien je dirais qu'il faut pénaliser
il faut sanctionner et certainement
beaucoup plus fort qu'on ne le fait
aujourd'hui moi je suis plutôt raide
dans une démarche qui consiste à dire
plus de sanctions mais pas géré et d'
atteinte à la compétitivité et à plus de
normes on en souffre déjà beaucoup ça
c'est ma première observation et la
seconde durait concerne beaucoup plus le
ministre de l'agro alimentaire j'ai noté
une de ses phrases tout à l'heure qui
disait je pense que ça va réjouir les
producteurs auraient finalement une à
une vraie problématique c'est que ray le
prix de la qualité n'est pas au rendez
vous alors
vrai savoir monsieur le ministre comment
on peut faire en sorte qu effectivement
mais on est des produits alimentaires
vendus au juste prix
parce que ça je pense que ça intéresse
beaucoup de monde et en particulier les
producteurs des produits des produits
qui sont vendus au juste prix
parce que effectivement on n'a pas de
tarif de première nécessité dans le
domaine alimentaire
donc comment on fait voilà c'est fait
merci monsieur mira soupe rapidement si
possible
oui moi je remercie les ministres
explications qui ont été données et
singulièrement propos ce qu'a dit
stéphane le foll instants qui a expliqué
le meilleur très clair qui est pas quand
même une génération spontanée des quêtes
donc ça veut dire qu'il ya eu fraude
c'est patent et en même temps au passage
pourquoi ne pas le dire quelques larmes
de crocodile de gens qui se sont
évertués pendant quelques heures a
expliqué aux salariés qui est en quelque
sorte les otages sains de suspension qui
étaient quasiment inévitables
et là il y avait des pensées et aussi
quelques arrière-pensées alors tout à
l'heure au renard expliqué qu' un profit
à court terme 6 mois de 550000 euros
encore 550 millions 758 votre raison on
comprend que ça que ça fasse travailler
les imaginations de ceux qui sont les
moins scrupuleux pour autant de même
discussions ont discuté des skis
circuits courts hélas pour les besoins
de la corde c'est plus un circuit court
ce n'est plus le grand huit cents corps
plus compliqué de sa veut dire qu'un
véritable problème qui se pose à
l'échelon européen
mais quand les gars on nous explique à
juste titre que c'est difficilement
compréhensible qu'on arrive en bout de
course à des plats cuisinés un ou deux
euros ça veut dire qu'à mohcine dans
l'intervalle que ça correspond à une
forme de demande
hall est en dépression on est en crise
pouvoir d'achat et il ya quelque sorte
l'effet d'aubaine et l'enjeu ça consiste
à faire en sorte qu' on puisse tirer le
qualitatif vers le haut tout en restant
dans un domaine qu'ils soient
accessibles sur le plan d'eau sur le
plan des prix à la vente et ça ça
concerne bien sûr l'hexagone mais bilan
de la halle
le niveau européen merci je dois dire
que par rapport à la remarque du
sénateur mirassou s'ils avaient de
lasagne à la viande de cheval c'était
pas un scandale et que au niveau
nutritionnel me
tu retailleau vous est taquin monsieur
le président toujours d'attaqué
alors quelques mots qu'elles s'exercent
souvent à mon encontre mais de façon
sympathique toujours plusieurs points le
premier c'est que je crois effectivement
pour dire ce que ce qui a déjà été dit
par d'autres que la réponse des uns des
autres a été je trouve très approprié je
pense que cette réponse doit être élargi
elle doit être élargie parce que on voit
bien qu'aujourd'hui le débat central
pour le relèvement économique de la
france c'est la réindustrialisation et
on a avec l'industrie agroalimentaire un
des atouts extraordinaires qui
récapitule en plus ce que nous sommes
la culture gastronomique l'agriculture
avec nos territoires
le savoir faire avec les process
industriels qu'on a inventé et je pense
que à chaque décision il faut conserver
à l'esprit cette donnée qui est
importante alors élargir la réponse ça
veut dire l'élargir vis-à-vis des
consommateurs traçabilité et
transparence soeur jumelle mêmes
siamoises ce que je veux dire quand même
c'est que sans faire du consumérisme
consumérisme parfois ça consiste à ce
que chaque ministre je vous le dis mais
c'est au delà des différents
gouvernements de droite et de gauche que
chaque ministre consommation fasse sa
loi les class actions
attention si oui pour la transparence
oui pour que le commence le consommateur
retrouve confiance
le curseur devra être ajusté réponse
élargit aussi sur la politique de la
filière
on est tous deux territoires et on voit
bien que les industries agroalimentaires
ont souvent de la peine alors que notre
agriculture et puissante qu'elle est
productive à utiliser les matières
premières
voilà pour cette audition nous
reviendrons bien entendu eu plus
largement dans notre édition de 19h sur
cette question de la viande de cheval
mais tout de suite c'est à l'émission
politique de la rédaction de public
sénat
preuve par 3 qui reçoit ce soir l'ancien
ministre et actuel député ump des
yvelines valérie pécresse bonne soirée à
tous